okay
my first chess game
of 2022
playing colin magruder
has never played a game before on each s
or at least our rating game
so
why am i seed number 89
well okay let's play stafford
this could be my first staffer gambit of
2022
okay staffer gamma time
no better way to start the year
i feel like i might get punished but
we'll see
i like the opponent is uh is thinking
here
i like that the opponent's thinking here
because
there's a lot of ways white can fall
into traps bishop two's the best move
um this is what i've been playing myself
recently against stafford
if white really knows what they're doing
it is
essentially one of the refutation lines
now bishop g5
is not the best move because it leaves
b2 undefended
i'm actually
yeah i guess bishop f2 doesn't quite
work but i have queen d4 so hitting f2
and b2
and the bishop e3 i can safely take the
pawn because takes and then takes
and then i'll be up material
kind of curious if castling
i'll consider knight g4
it looks interesting
because i hit f2
[Music]
i'm looking at the line c3 queen e5
hitting the bishop and threatening mate
if takes takes i'm still threatening
mate and the bishop
and white doesn't have time for d4
and there's not even f4 because i pin
i control these squares so the bishop
can't really defend
okay so we go into this line
now knight d2 probably coming
wait a minute
what did anybody play against me
i feel like anybody somehow sucked their
rook
on a1 we had like a fun blitz game in
russia where he he invented the counter
gambit
to the staffer gambit
but maybe it was a slightly different
line
okay so here i'm not winning the rook
i think it makes sense to take the
bishop first
and then
the queen probably wants to return to
the center
although
i play this there's knight here but then
queen c3 check
i have some idea of queen g5 hitting
this pawn and this pawn
okay so i would say this is a pretty
successful opening
of course it's still very playable for
white
equal material
but i won the pawn back have some
initiative now
i think the knight's going to have to
return to d2
there were a few legal moves there
now i want to play this move
but i also kind of want to play this
move
maybe this is better
the idea of bishop g4
is i want to deflect the queen away from
defending c2
and if we trade then e3 is weak
let's do it
yeah so i want my nylon g4
which is why i play bishop g4 so i want
to trade off the bishops
i love you too
cine tolerate
resign to lore
not sure whether to pronounce that as
spanish or
english
yeah white's under pressure here
so these things are kind of pinned to
the the larger things
queen is tied down to defending stuff
really can't complain
there's a question why not queen
deforted the pawn
um
i don't know if it was
the most recent position but
yeah pawns can take diagonally
i did play queen d4 earlier
to
hit multiple pawns
okay so
i'm up upon
but i have to be careful white has three
center pawns
i have none
and now i have some initiative too
i'm bringing the knight
i'm looking at
and if queen f2 i probably just castle
because then it takes i win the knights
thank you lerp88
and albinor
i know gino
oh yeah i guess my
my mug and shirt are matching today
we still have the merch command
okay so rook c1
i was thinking about knight c3 but it
doesn't work
the knight c3 those takes takes king f2
my knight would be trapped
so i'll play this move
now i've accessed the king side
if rook b1
[Music]
things might get a bit spicy
rock bean one
so i might end up casting queen sign
and then rook lift attack
oh there's also rook c4 here
or d4
okay now i'm thinking queen a3 hitting
this pawn
[Music]
but then knight c4 attacking defending
queen e7
i don't mind that
because once a knight comes to c4 it
looks like a decent piece but
it can't really
do much
beyond that i mean maybe there's 95
ideas
hey the first merch purchase of the year
thanks
i don't know how to pronounce that name
but thank you
okay time to quack at the queen
so white has to be really careful not to
get forked
if queen here here
i would fork on d3 although then there
was queen e3
but now another fork is coming
mainly hitting the king in the rook
okay life is pretty good
this is okay
fun
having lots of fun
so
white wants to get revenge by forking me
i'm calculating rook t4 knight f7
rook cafe king e3
because there's a weird line like rook
a4 e6 rookie rook d1 and if i take the
pawn i get mated
and the thread is e7 rook t8
so
it might be safer
doing something else
ah maybe uh takes takes and then rookie
immediately
yeah let's do that
okay here i can play rook d7
defending f7
so if i had to estimate my opponent's
rating
definitely above 1500
at least like 18 or 1900
because the mistakes this game weren't
like super
beginner level
the position kind of gradually
crumbled for white
and the main mistake was getting forked
with the 92 move
wanna win stuff
a4 is a good move
i'll play g5
supports the pawn
the plan is this and then this
okay maybe i'll come around
come from behind
idea rookie one
allowing this i just want to get the
rooks
doing things
okay we'll make luft
a5
and then this move
i'm gradually preparing the latter mates
how is this game going to end
oh that's how it ends
so no checkmates yet in 2022.
uh but thanks for the game colin
magruder
um
yeah opponent kind of walked into
this queen d4 move
and
maybe white's white's still probably
objectively better
oh wow best move bishop h4
kind of hard to play
bishop e3 was playing
okay and then blacks for choice
okay first staffer gambit of 2022
complete
many more
staffords to come probably